[Musique]
on
ce visage rempli d'émotions c'est celui
de la nageuse carla link en 1976 âgé d'à
peine 16 ans elle va prendre part à deux
finales olympiques aux 100 et 200 m
brasse
elle est une des favorites car à
l'époque elle était détentrice du record
du monde
elle finira 5e et 8e une grande
déception pour elle et son équipe
quarante deux ans plus tard les
souvenirs remontent rapidement à la
surface
[Musique]
je ne peux même pas écrire c'est une
émotion incroyable j'ai vécu de belles
choses ici je ne pensais pas venir un
jour car la link semble savourer chaque
recoin de cette piscine olympique qui a
bien changé depuis 42 ans
quand on l'amène sur les lieux du bassin
d'entraînement qui lui est demeuré
intact
tous ces souvenirs se bousculent et moi
ça a été ça me rappelle le temps où on
s'entraînait bakou on était avec les
autres nageurs de partout dans le monde
c'était une communauté les nageuses de
la rda impressionné par leur physique
imposant
on découvrira plus tard que le pays
avait mis sur pied un vaste programme de
dopage institutionnels un dopage de
masse surveillé par la stasi la police
secrète de l'époque
plus de dix mille athlètes en seront
victimes
les conséquences seront dramatiques
cancers malformations chez les enfants
certaines femmes étaient tellement dopé
aux hormones mâles qu'elles ont dû
changer de sexe un sujet qui est encore
sensible aujourd'hui nous étions fiers à
l'époque le dopage
nous n'en étions pas trop beau courant
l'avons appris que par la suite
ça m'attriste mais ça me met surtout en
colère
moi je vais bien je n'ai pas de
séquelles et deux enfants sont en santé
mais évidemment je pense à sucre et j'ai
eu connaissance de quelques cas les
détails des procès seront intentés par
les athlètes victime du dopage
quelques responsables subiront des
peines légères comme si on avait voulu
enterrer le passé certains entraîneurs
de l'époque qui ont fui la rda après la
chute du mur de berlin sont encore en
poste dans certains pays comme l'afrique
du sud
car la linke elle est heureuse de
retrouver cette piscine olympique est la
faire découvrir à son fils nouvellement
installé à montréal
une fierté pour elle ne lui faire
connaître son passé
quand vous aimez votre entraînement
croyez vous entraînez vous pour ça c'est
une expérience extraordinaire que
janvier est forte si vous gagnez une
médaille ou non ce sont les jeux vous
êtes aux jeux olympiques
car la regarder avec beaucoup
d'attention et d'émotion la plaque
commémorative de son équipe médaillé
olympique
chaque nom résonnait dans sa mémoire
comme si elle était encore la petite
adolescente de 1976 mais l'émotion a
atteint son paroxysme
carla à une opération finish au avec la
surprise qu'on lui avait réservé
thomas ce malgré les blessures du passé
une chose est certaine c'est qu'on ne
pourra jamais enlever à carla link
qu'elle est et restera pour toujours une
olympienne robert frosi radio canada
montréal